death of a man who literally changed the
way we live our lives every day Steve
Jobs the Visionary founder and leader of
Apple computer has died at the age of
56. on October 5th 2022 it officially
became 11 years since Steve Jobs passed
away many believed that Apple would lose
their Touch without Steve and that
things just wouldn't be the same and
while that may be true there's no
arguing that Tim Cook has done a
phenomenal job at least from a financial
perspective Tim has been able to grow
Apple's net income from 25 billion
dollars per year which is already nuts
to 100 billion dollars per year this has
resulted in Apple stock growing over 10x
and apple becoming the world's first
public coin dollar company and
eventually the world's first three twin
doll company considering this tremendous
performance no shareholder is really
asking for Tim Cook to step down but at
61 years old it looks like Tim himself
is is ready to call it a day within the
next couple of years while Tim has yet
to reveal an exact date for his
retirement he did give a couple of Clues
as to when he may be departing in April
of 2021 Tim announced that he probably
would not be running Apple in 10 years
and is that he's looking to oversee the
launch of just one more product category
some have speculated that this might be
the Apple car but more than likely he's
probably talking about some sort of AR
VR headset rumors surrounding this
headset have become a rampant and top
analysts like government and quo have
suggested that this headset may be
launched as early as the end of this
year even if that doesn't come to
fruition it seems like the headset
should definitely come out within the
next one to two years I think it's
pretty safe to assume that Tim would
probably want to stick around for a few
years after launch to make sure
everything is going smoothly before he
retires so that would put his estimated
retirement date at somewhere between
2025 and 2028. come combine this with
the fact that Tim's next stock
compensation package will finish paying
God in 2025 and a retirement shortly
after that makes a lot of sense but all
of this brings up the question who will
become the next CEO of the world's
largest company
starting off with the most likely choice
we have the second to most important
person at Apple Jeff Williams Jeff is
currently the CEO or chief operating
officer of Apple and he has quite an
extent to background in terms of
Education Jeff is actually an engineer
having earned a mechanical engineering
degree from North Carolina State
University he followed this up with an
MBA from Duke University one of the
first companies that Jeff worked for
after graduation was IBM he joined the
company in 1985 and spent the next 13
years on a variety of roles related to
engineering and operations it was until
1998 that Jeff joined apple as a head of
worldwide procurement from there he was
promoted to being a vice president of
operations in 2004 and head of worldwide
operations in 2010 and finally at the
end of 2015 he was promoted to his
current role at SEO operations isn't the
only thing he takes care of though after
Johnny Ive left Apple in 2019 Jeff
oversaw Apple's design Department as
well in terms of why is a top candidate
there's a lot of reasons first of all
he's an engineer and in recent history
we've been seeing a trend away from
business CEOs and towards technical CEOs
Tim Cook himself is an engineer and the
same thing could be said about the CEOs
of Microsoft Google Nvidia and AMD just
to name a few so Jeff fits the perfect
modern CEO mode of having a lot of
business experience but also having a
lot of technical knowledge as well we
should also noted that Tim Cook himself
was CEO before moving up to CEO also
historically speaking 76 percent of sndp
500 CEOs were promoted from being CEOs
however we have started to see a shift
in this trend as of 2020 only 38 percent
of CEOs were being promoted from being
CEOs nearly the same amount were being
promoted from roles as divisional CEOs
or essentially vice presidents
nonetheless if Tim Cook were to leave
tomorrow unexpectedly Jeff Williams
would almost definitely be the one to
take over however Tim is isn't leaving
tomorrow there's still years before his
departure and this alone reduces Jeff
Chance's substantially Jeff is only two
years younger than Tim at 59 years old
if Tim were to leave in 2028 Jeff would
already be 65 years old by then and if
Apple wants another leader who can lead
for more than 10 or 15 years Jeff just
doesn't seem like the best choice but
aside from this one point Jeff has
everything going for him
moving on to our next candidate we have
Eddie Q who is the senior vice president
of services if we're talking about
someone who is loyal to Apple Eddie
isn't definitely the guy as Apple has
essentially been his entire career after
graduating from Duke University with the
bachelors in computer science and
economics Eddie joined Apple in 1989 at
the age of 25 and he's been there ever
since Eddie is one of those guys who
never worked on something that the
average customer really ever
acknowledges he wasn't the one that
designed the iPhone or the airpods or
face idea or anything like that but he
has been integral to the Apple
experience since day one and he has hit
home run after home run first 1998 he
led development of the Apple website
then in 2003 he led items development
and in 2008 he led App Store development
since then he has also worked on Apple
Maps iCloud iMessage Siri and literally
every other Apple service you can think
of here's a full list of all of the
services that you overseeing right now
basically if it's a service and it's
from Apple this guy has played some role
in it this means that Eddie is The
Mastermind behind the Apple experience
and given that apple is extremely
focused on the Apple ecosystem and
preventing users from leaving it and he
could be the perfect choice for a CEO
after all there's only so many iPhones
that Apple can sell and if we're not
already at Peak iPhone we'll definitely
be there by the time Tim retires so
Apple can't continue to increase profits
in Revenue just through Hardware Sales
they continue growing apple needs to
increase revenue and profit through
services and that's exactly what they've
been trying to do ever since the iPhone
sales peaked a couple of years ago but
despite their efforts apple is still
very much a hardware company as opposed
to a Services Company Eddie however
could change that and get apple to the
10 trillion dollar mark from a business
strategy point of view I think Eddie is
by far the best choice the next stage
for apple is to transition it into being
a services company and there's simply no
better guide to lead that than Eddie
like Jeff though Eddie does fall short
in a few aspects first of all Eddie has
virtually no experience outside of
services he doesn't have significant
experience relating to operations
Finance branding or any of the other
aspects that go into running a company
also he's not that much younger than Tim
either coming in at 57. likely the
biggest drawback however is that the
Apple Community as a whole isn't the
biggest fans of Eddie there's literally
Reddit threads about my Apple should let
go of Eddie the general consensus seems
to be that Eddie used to lead great
things but that his current work just
doesn't quite stack up if we look past
that though Eddie is likely the best
choice in terms of making apple into a
Services Giant
foreign
is currently the senior vice president
of worldwide marketing Greg is one of
those people who ended up doing
something that's completely unrelated to
their educational background like Jeff
and Eddie Greg is also an engineer at
heart but he's never actually been an
engineer in practice he graduated from
the University of Michigan in 1986 with
the computer engineering degree and he
was recruited to Apple directly from
college originally he was hired to work
on the Macintosh but it didn't take him
long to switch over to marketing and
that's what he's been doing for over 30
years now the first major marketing
effort that he led at Apple was related
to the power book after this he switched
over to Leading the marketing effort for
the iPod and eventually the iPhone and
just two years ago after Phil Schiller
stepped down Greg took on the role of
senior vice president Greg is kind of a
tricky one to evaluate he has a
technical background he clearly knows
how to market products and he would
likely lead apple as a product oriented
company but while this is the approach
that has worked historically it's not
clear if this is the way moving forward
as we previously touched on it seems
that most of Apple's future growth lies
within services and that this is not
something that Greg really has
experience in to me it seems like Greg
simply fits in his current role much
better but this isn't to say that Greg
would be a bad CEO he'd probably take
Apple's branding and marketing to the
next level and that could be helpful
with new product launches like the AR VR
headset and maybe even the Apple car but
it's hard to see how Greg would
diversify Apple's revenue and to take
apple to the next level and given that
this is usually shareholder's top
priority Greg probably isn't the top
choice but at the same time given that
apple is a part-oriented company at
their core and that Greg is the most
experienced Apple employee on the
executive team we definitely can't write
them off
foreign
get into the fan favorite I thought we
should cover some of the oddballs that
have a shot at the job first we have a
look at my history who is the CFO of
Apple Luca has spent his entire career
within Finance which makes sense given
that he has a bachelor's in economics
and a masters in management his
experience includes GM Nokia Xerox and
of course Apple if Apple was
experiencing a cash crunch or debt
crisis maybe Luca would have been a good
choice but at this point there doesn't
seem to be anything going for Luca other
than the fact that he's also a c-suite
executive moving on to our next Oddball
we have John turnus who is the senior
vice president of Hardware engineering
John has a bachelor's in mechanical
engineering from the University of
Pennsylvania and he's been with Apple
for a little more than 20 years now he's
currently in charge of leading the
engineering for the iPhone the iPad the
mac airpods and more John is definitely
more of a product guy but what makes him
especially interesting is his age John
is the youngest member of Apple's
executive team coming in at just 45
years old so he could easily serve SEO
for 15 years or more but aside from that
nothing particularly sticks out about
Jon next up we have the only woman on
our list yerdra O'Brien Deirdre is
actually ranked as one of the most
powerful women in the world and given
her position this is not too surprising
Deirdre is in charge of the vast
majority of Apple's employees because
she is the vice president of retail and
the people she has a degree in
operations management and an MBA and
like many of the other people on this
list she has spent her entire life at
Apple there's no doubt that she is
qualified for the position but with so
many other qualified individuals on this
list there doesn't seem to be any key
reason why she would get the Java over
any of them and finally to wrap up the
Oddball list we have at Phil Schiller
Phil needs no introduction as he is one
of the most recognizable Apple
Executives of all time he's been a part
of Apple's Keynotes for ages even during
the Steve Jobs era and he was probably a
top Contender ever CEO even in 2011 but
today he's not that big of a contender
because he's essentially retired he
stepped down as vice president a few
years ago and he holds an honorary title
as Apple fellow and at 62 years old it's
unlikely that Apple will choose someone
who is basically retired
someone else who doesn't need an
introduction is Craig federighi who has
become synonymous with apple Keynotes
quagga AKA Air Force One is by far the
most charismatic and Lively presenter at
Apple and it seems that his charm has
won over much of the Apple fan base I
suspect that he reminds them of the
Steve Jobs days in terms of
qualifications Craig is just as
qualified as anyone else on this list
Craig has a bachelor's in computer
science and electrical engineering from
Berkeley he also has a masters in
computer science also from Berkeley
initially he got acquainted with Steve
Jobs at next where he led Enterprise
objects framework when Apple acquired
next he became an Apple employee but he
didn't stick around for long though in
1999 she would switch over to a company
called Ariba where he would eventually
become CTO but Craig would eventually
return to Apple in 2009 and has since
become the senior vice president of
software engineering if we're talking
just about technical know-how I don't
think there's anyone on Apple's
executive team that's more technical
experience than Craig not to mention
Craig is relatively young for being an
apple executive while he's not as young
as John turn is he's only 53 years old
meaning that he could easily serve as
CEO for 10 years if not more maybe the
only thing that's not going in Craig's
favor is that he doesn't have much
experience outside of software but this
is true for many Tech CEOs so I don't
think it's much of a limiting factor now
Craig has stated in the past that he's
not looking to become a CEO but honestly
that literally means nothing I mean what
is he supposed to say saying that he
wants to be CEO would it just make him
look power hungry and arrogant so
ironically saying that he doesn't want
the job is actually his best play to get
the job now there is a subset of the
Apple community that strongly opposes
Craig they don't think that the position
of CEO should go to someone that they
view it as an Entertainer and a meme but
you know any CEO is going to have haters
and it's no different with Craig
in the end if I had to rank the
candidates by likelihood I would have to
go with the traditional choices which
are of course Jeff Williams followed up
by Greg joswiak if Apple wanted to put a
strategic Twist on this and focus on
Services they might go with erikira
while these guys are no doubt the top
choices today given their ages I think
there's a good chance that Apple decides
to go with someone younger by the time
Tim retires and if this is the case I
think Craig has a strong shot at the job
given his age Charisma and fandom
personally I think he'd bring a
refreshing spin to Apple and I'd love to
see him get the job but that's just what
I think are you a fan of Craig becoming
the next CEO of Apple comment that down
below also drop a like if you're excited
to see Tim's final product category and
of course consider checking out our
Discord Community to just put your video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
foreign